alors que samedi the voice revenait
après plusieurs semaines d'interruption
voilà que la fête a été gâchée par
plusieurs soupçons de trucage
en effet plusieurs internautes pensent
que les votes auraient été manipulés par
tf1 c'est suite à la sélection étonnante
de certains candidats que des
internautes ont recommencé à se poser
des questions sur les réseaux sociaux
plusieurs téléspectateurs n'ont pas
hésité à formuler leurs doutes du style
en finale c'est une blague
l'émission semble truqués en plus on ne
voit pas les résultats chiffrés du vote
pourquoi ou encore pardon on vient de me
dire que les votes qui compte réellement
de nous c'est à partir de la finale mais
là nos votes c'est juste pour la thune
de tf1 choqué des accusations auxquelles
n'ont pas encore répondu ni la chaîne ni
le producteur du jeu
alors c'est vrai que là ça commence à
faire beaucoup sur the voice les pauvres
maxime guinea est-ce qu'on a des infos
là dessus elle seule information c'est
que les deux tiers de ce que vous avez
vu l'autre jour en prime time ont été
pré enregistrée mardi
donc évidemment la boyne but
téléspectateurs c'est pas vrai bon temps
le seul tiers retourner en direct
c'était la dernière partie de l'émission
et on fait exactement la même mécanique
sur la même si l'achat de trois semaines
je vous somme perdue
en plus moi je trouve que c'est vraiment
une connerie tf1 ils ont annoncé
aujourd'hui qu'ils auraient pas de danse
etc les cas à la rentrée puis je dire
pourquoi ne pas avoir mis the voice
voilà à la rentrée à la limite vous
faites les trois dernières de the voice
à la rentrée au moins ça leur met 3 prem
le professeur a oui dit quoi il devait y
avoir une règle dit quoi dire après pas
forcément un candidat par coach qui
était qualifié comme par hasard les
quatre coachs rang final
c'est de la manipulation évidemment
comme d'habitude on réclame à chaque
fois qu'ils nous donnent les résultats
il ne les datations garder gardez vous
gardez vos distances
oui il ne les donnent pas les résultats
parce qu'évidemment les votes sont
manipulés c'est obligatoire sur cette
élection libre au dessus chloroquine à
sur l'hydraulique laurent oui on peut
pas dire que les balaurs moi moi j'ai
été déçu comme tout le monde par la demi
finale mais bon je retiens enfin petit
partenaire manipuler parce que les
résultats vous dresse pas - justin en
finale je suis très contente
la jeune dame et liste j'ai trouvé très
bien qu'il faut se traduisait harpiste
bienvenue aux toilettes
[Rires]
j'entends ce que tu dis et moi je suis
tue c'est bien la première à ne pas
aimer les théories du complot de gilles
dit ajoutant elle d'être exclu par tous
il n'empêche qu'on peut quand même à
minima se poser la question en se disant
c'est quand même étonnant que comme par
hasard il y ait un candidat par coach se
faisant même apprendrait des questions
non mais je le mets ça arrivera les
distances des trois la question
pensez-vous
non non non plus plus c'est vous merci
merci oui oui il aime elle qui a un
candidat qui était choisi pour la finale
sa thèse c'est pas un argument ça on
s'en tape complètement le truc c'est
qu'il pourquoi ils sont pas affichés les
résultats avec le nombre de
téléspectateurs le pourcentage assez
bizarre c'est quand même bizarre c'est
évidemment le fait nous tous les jours
dans sécu du kif
ah oui au fait que les critiques ont
fait des sondages sur la pige en deux
secondes les résultats en direct
apparemment c'était pas d'hier elle
investit en direct mode et du jus de
chaque candidat qui changera oui là ce
avait été enregistré le démarrage
correct mais après en revanche quand
nikos arrivent en disant maintenant
c'est l'heure des votes je l'avais temps
17 mars alors direct rien léger 10
n'était pas en direct mais pas vraiment
direct ça va le voir mais dans tous les
cas que ce soit mérité ou pas c'est
juste hyper grave de palau sur le
résultat le pourcentage par respect pour
les gens qui votent
moi si j'étais quelqu'un qui votaient
pour cette émission j'aurais pas du tout
envie de voter la prochaine fois c'est
que je me dis qu'il se fout de ce que
penser qu'ils ont tué the voice moi je
promets que les deux mois je pense que
ce gros signal est candidat on connait
rien je vais vous dire moi si j'étais
tf1 là il faut vraiment parce que moi
moi je me couche je le dis et je trouve
que en ce moment pas nikos il le met que
sur des tas nas 50 minutes inside
c'est une tana ça marche pas du tout the
voice ils ont cramé avec the voice donc
là la priorité tf1 pour moi cet été chez
de trouver un programme pour nicolas
vimont valérian l'ap le public c'est
important oui mont valérien
moi je trouve que par rapport aux
programmes de tf1 en ce moment que ce
soit ce vol
danse avec les stars il faudrait qu'ils
aient du renouveau ça s'essouffle un
petit peu à chaque fois ils n'arrivent
pas à se réinventer chaque saison et on
a l'impression toutes les saisons année
après année on voit à peu près la même
chose l'ombre moi tu mets beaucoup le
jury de the voice et et le sol
apparemment citalis presque
s'est fait fracasser et mine de rien
tout le monde m'avait dit au départ the
voice va prendre une énorme touche
j'avais dit non et en fait je me suis
trompé parce que c'est vrai que the
voice est catastrophique cette année ils
étaient les spectateurs
les candidats accroché paquereau schiste
n'ont pas continué valais on avait
évoqué un retour de la star ac
peut-être que c'est l'alternative à de
voice search sur laisser reposer la
martre et reprendre éventuellement star
ac et ça ferait du bien à de voice de
faire une ou deux saisons off et le
séjour blanche voilà c'est dit allez on
classe m et ça sera un crack c'est pas
liée au nombre d'animaux ce koh lanta 19
ans a rien à voir
voilà entassés programme le plus fort il
y avait la ville accueille volontariat
l'année oui ça a rien à voir des
chanteurs ont besoin d'avoir un qi
d'avoir à les poches on entend la
compréhension non mais c'est vrai des
mecs sur un poteau on ne s'en lassera on
se lassera jamais mec qui chante on s'en
tape total et puis koh lanta cette année
il y avait un casting exceptionnel on
aura l'occasion de leur parler il ya
purée avec cette semaine les gens
chantent bien à chaque fois ils chantent
tous bien c'est fantastique ce qu'il se
souvient de qui a gagné l'année dernière
mais le peu de plaisir je sais même pas
voilà ben arous et pas personne ne sait
s crois qu'ils s'appellent l'anglais
parce qu'ils passent un clip tf1 passe
un clip d'elle sur son album mais
personne ne sait pour valls appelle
vêtements personnes professeurs ce qui a
manqué c'est aller évidemment c'est que
c'était d'abord en pécs et qui avait pas
de public que lara fabian et à part ça
montréal rien à voir c'est à la fin de
la saison c'est qu'à la fin à 23h23
quand ils ont démarré les pseudos direct
c'est vrai que c'était extrêmement
décevant quand on a suivi toutes les
missions de retrouver par exemple
gustine que moi en revanche j'ai pas
aimé du tout il avait tellement mieux
qu'elle comme cheyen qui était
formidable et de sacs à énerver tout le
monde ailleurs on avait un peu oublié
les candidats pardon mais moi qui allais
oublier les candidats ce qu'on les a
laissés au début février qu'elle croit
comme ça et on les retrouve un mois et
demi deux mois après il ya eu ce 8 mai
kégué dernière les parties à houston je
comprends ce que tu dis valley a juste
l'empreinte de casting parce que les
candidats on les a pas du tout retenu on
sait pas du tout si c'est bien que mamie
nous qui les connaît pascal au regard
des rappels non mais voilà la raison
tous les cas moi je pense que bâle a
raison il faudrait remplacer par la star
ac parce que les gens qui chantent on a
juste totalement marque je reste qu'au
final il n'y a que des gens qui chantent
bien donc c'est cool
il ya pas de rebondissements c'est assez
plat comme l'émission il faudrait des
gens qui chantent qui danse et qui
malheureusement les gens aiment beaucoup
la réalité la sérénité alors qu'il faut
des histoires nombre de transferts qui a
raison alors il ya clément guérin donc
qui a dit qu'il n'y aurait pas de danse
avec les stars
notre ami clément qui sera de retour la
saison prochaine avec nous qui a dit
qu'il n'y aurait pas de danse avec les
stars sera la rentrée alors la raison
invoquée par tf1 à la rentrée sont déjà
prévues koh lanta masse singer the voice
quitte donc dit compliqué de caser dans
sa carrière parce qu ils ont une star
atef ils ont au clos de ken scott ils
auraient pu le foot dans danse avec les
stars tout le monde va regarder danse
avec les stars juste pour claude ils
font pas je crois qu'ils vont mettre
dans le rythme et paul déguisant d'enfin
mettre aux normes ce qui coûte que
j'adore j'espère le rencontrer en vrai
un jour ses héros et super laurence avec
legendary pourquoi c'est repoussé on
peut pas respecter les gestes barrière
en dansant et peut pas danser à deux
mètres bien sûr il se passe chez m&g
d'amis tout est calme et vous un peu là
oui sophy mais c'était ça la raison en
fait au départ évoquée par tns
financière c'est que les québécois nous
sortir la salle du chapeau je vois pas
comment dans un château on peut
respecter les est léger on peut plus que
je pensais danse avec les stars des
animaux ces démissions la plus touchée
par ce soir les gestes barrière oui mais
l'accès par mois non mais tout le monde
n'a pas du tout eu les confine à 20 a
bien sûr la même ville 15 jours non mais
ça a rien à voir en tout quinze jours
ensemble avant qui ensuite une fois
qu'ils sont tous savent que c'est qu'ils
sont tous accusés mais dans un château
alors d'aller faire la même chose avec
avec danse mcchrystal on parle dans
trois mois et demi quatre mois qu'il
annulera voulez que je dise la vérité
je pense que ça leur coûte beaucoup et
qu' ils se disent les audiences elles
sont folles ça vous savez quoi on a un
combat voilà the voice qu'ils ont un
truc c'est bon les mêmes intervilles moi
je pense que c'est surtout des coupes
dans le budget voilà et on va pas se
mentir on connaît un petit peu le ce qui
se passe voilà au sein de l'homme
ensemble de la télévision france inter